Before reducing 3-CNF to subset sum,
we have to define the subset
sum problem first.
We're given a multi set of numbers, A,
consisting of numbers a1 through am,
where each element is
a positive integer.
A multiset by the way,
is just a set that allows the same
element to be included more than once.
So this set might include three 5's,
two 20s, and just one 31, for example.
And we're also given a number k.
The problem is to decide whether
there is a subset of this multiset,
whose members add up to k.
One instance of this
problem is partitioning.
And I'll use this particular
example to illustrate.
Imagine that you want to divide
assets evenly between two parties.
Maybe we're picking
teams on the playground,
trying to reach a divorce settlement,
dividing spoils among the victors of
war, or something of that nature.
Then the question becomes,
is there a way to partition a set so
that things come out even?
Each side getting exactly one half.
In this case the total is 18.
So we should choose k
to be equal to 9 and
ask if there is a way to
get a subset to sum to 9.
And indeed there is.
We can choose two 1s and a 7,
and that will give us 9.
So, yes.
So would 4 and 5, of course.
That's the subset sum problem.
Note that the problem isn't
NP because given any subset,
it takes polynomial time to add up
the numbers and see if the sum equals k.
Finding the right subset,
however, seems much harder.
We don't know of a way to do it that's
necessarily faster than just trying
all two to the m subsets.